je suis désolé pour votre perte
je sais que c'est un cap très dur à
passer pour le voir autrement penser à
cette force de la nature à l'intérieur
de vous le bébé c'est ce qui doit être
fait le bébé va même vous dire ce que
vous devez faire c'est ainsi que la
nature fonctionne la nature elle fait
aussi pas mal de coups de [ __ ] non
j'étais libre ou y de mieux en mieux à
chaque fois c'est plus moi qui contrôle
je veux pas voir à quoi il ressemble
s'en fout la trouille
j'aimerais pouvoir les changer pour le
récupérer lui gaudet ne vous entend pas
détrompez-vous escape to try and kill ou
six mois qui te tuerais tu vois un truc
c'était là pour faire la fête
tu as bien choisi l'endroit je passe du
côté obscur vous croiriez pas du tout ce
que j'ai fait ces derniers temps propre
et sans bavure
avez vous entendu parler du mouvement
sauvons les enfants
vous êtes ce que je suis c'est une mère
qui travaille les gosses sont pourris
gâtés de nos jours et c'est maman va s'y
prend mois une playstation et tue moi ce
mec
tu t'écoutes est plutôt ma voix mois
[Applaudissements]
je ferai tout ce que tu me dit de faire
son bien que des cochons
écoutez re être négatif c'est pas bon
pour la petite
vous croyez
[Musique]